قد تكون الرياضه طريقا للسلام واليوم وبعد
عام من الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه تتبنى
اللجنه الاولمبيه هذه الفكره في التفاصيل
اللجنه تبحث عن طريقه للسماح للرياضيين
الروس بالمشاركه بدوره الالعاب الاولمبيه
الصيفيه المقبله في باريس اللجنه
الاولمبيه الدوليه ترى انه من المهم
السماح لروسيا وبيلاروسيا بالتنافس
بالعابها دون رموز وعلى وطنيه لكن الامر
قد لا يعجب الرياضيين الروس واللجنه
الاولمبيه الروسيه التي قد ترى انه من
السيء ان يلعب رياضي يوها دون اعلام كل
ذلك ياتي في ظل استمرار الرفض الدولي
للرياضيين الروس الامر الذي يسبب صدعا في
الرياضه العالميه
على كل حال مزيد من التفاصيل سنتحدث عنها
بعد قليل لاثر هذه الصراعات التاريخيه كيف
بدات وما هي تداعياتها حتى اليوم لميس
روسيا
ليست اول الدول التي تحرم من المشاركه
رياضيا في العالم بسبب الحرب في عام
1936 ظهرت حركه لمقاطعه برلين ايام الحكم
النازي لكنها فشلت بسبب رفض دمج السياسه
بالرياضه من قبل اللجنه الاولمبيه وشاركت
49 دوله وهو عدد فاقع عدد الفرق التي
شاركت في اي اولمبياد من قبل في عام 1948
ستوب بعدت المانيا واليابان من دوله
الالعاب الاولمبيه في لندن عقب نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهزمتهما فيها
وكان للحرب البارده اثرها على الرياضه
الاولمبيه حيث انسحبت الولايات المتحده
واكثر من 60 من حلفائها من دوره العاب
موسكو
وفي عام
1984 كان الرد الروسي على الولايات
المتحده حيث انسحبت هي وحلفائها ايضا
الاولمبياد لوس انجلوس كرد قوي على واشنطن
[موسيقى]
صباح العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد عبد
الجوادي يسعد صباحك كيف هو التفاعل مع
مساعي اللجنه الاوروبيه لاعاده اللاعبين
الروس
صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير نادي نعم هيا
قضيه يعني معقده وقاسيه للغايه ليست هي
المره الاولى التي يتم فيها حرمان
روسيا من المشاركه في دوره الالعاب
الاولمبيه ان كانت صيفيه او شتويه تحت
رايه او تحتها العلم الروسي طبعا هو
اقتراح كبير كانت موسكو قد مرت به في عام
2016 وفي عام 2018 وفي عام 2021
تحت رايه العلم الاولمبي هو اقتراح طبعا
ممكن من خلاله الوصول وتقديم الرياضيين
الروسي للمشاركه في هذه الالعاب الاولمبيه
باعتبار ان الرياضيين الذين يقومون بتحضير
يعني بالتحضير للدخول في المنافسات
الاولمبيه لهم سنوات طويله من التحضير
واللجنه الاولمبيه ان كانت الدوليه او
روسيه ترى في هذا الموضوع ضروره لعدم
خذلان هؤلاء الرياضيين للوصول نحو الالعاب
الاولمبيه القضيه سهام طبعا لها بعض طويل
بدات في عام 2014 لابد من لفت الانتباه
بان التاريخ دوما يشهد ان منتخب الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق او منتخب روسيا يشغل
المرتبه الثانيه او الثالثه على لائحه
الترتيب العام بعدد الميداليات الذهبيه في
الاولمبياد الصيفي والمرتبه السادسه او
السابعه في الاولمبياد الشتوي لكن دوره
الالعاب الاولمبيه الشتويه في جنوب الروسي
عام 2014 شهدت ضغوطات كبيره من جهه طبعا
قامت موسكو باستق باستقطاب لاعبين اجانب
منهم فيكتور ان طبعا الذي احرز ثلاثه
ميداليات ذهبيه لروسيا بالتزحلق السريع
وايضا لاعب امريكي طبعا الذي الذي احرز
ذهبيه طبعا 500
ذهبيه لمجنسين وضعوا منتخب روسيا في
المرتبه الاولى برصيد 11 ميد
اوجد صراع كبير بين موسكو والغرب
تفضلت سبع نسخ اولمبيه وكنت شاهد على كل
تفاصيل هاي الموضوع حتى انك حملت شعله
الاولمبيه في 2014 والعالم الاولمبي في
2010 بس انا اليوم كمان بدنا نلخص الموضوع
تاثير صراع موسكو والغرب على عالم الرياضه
والالعاب الاولمبيه بالتحديد
طبعا يعني من يقول بان الرياضه هي بعيده
عن السياسه هو مخطئ بشكل كبير يعني اتحدث
لك بكل شفافيه بعد ان قضيت عاما كاملا في
اخر 20 سنه من حياتي في الدورات الاولمبيه
طبعا الميثاق الاولمبي ينادي دوما بعدم
ربط السياسه بالرياضه لكن هو واقع الحال
يلقي بذلك بظلاله على عالم الرياضه طبعا
كنا نلاحظ خلال الدورات الاولمبيه الصراع
وان كان بالتصريحات بين موسكو من الشرق
وبين واشنطن من الغرب يعني وصل الى حد
المقاطعه في العديد من الدورات الاولمبيه
لذلك طبعا لا يمكن فصل هذا الموضوع بشكل
كبير ودوما السياسه تلقي بظلالها بشكل
كبير على مشاركه الرياضيين طبعا الشيء
الوحيد الذي لم الحظه خلال عملي في المجال
الرياضي في العالم بان العالم العربي
عندما يشهد صراعات بين دول لابد من مشاركه
رياضيه وهذه الدول في كافه المسابقات
الرياضيه اينما وجد الشرق الاوسط واينما
وجدت في العالم العربي
نتيجه احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر ونتمنى
لقائك قريبا وتكون كمان حامل شعله اولمبيه
مقبله شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو مراسل صباح
العربي عبد الجواد رشمت